et maintenant la dernière interview l'interview du
concours mmm quelle est votre
position sur l'avortement vous savez si
c'était un homme dans cette situation je pense qu'il
n'aurait même jamais été question
qu'il aurait eu le droit de faire
ce qu'il veut mais puisque c'est  une femme,
cela semble un peu absurde quelle est votre
position sur l'euthanasie je pense
qu'à un moment donné c'est probablement bien parce que
si tout le monde est d'accord c'est peut-être
la meilleure chose à faire la peine de mort je pense que
certaines personnes méritent probablement la
peine de mort et ne devraient pas être là  et je
sais que je pourrais parler pour vous savez que je
pourrais parler de préserver la vie d'
une personne qui était mais je ne peux pas je ne
pourrais jamais parler pour la famille
qui a perdu l'enfant le mari la
pensée de la femme qui était  tué par
l'autre personne
et si j'étais dans cette personne, je voudrais
probablement vouloir au moins une
condamnation à mort à propos de la légalisation des
drogues douces peut-être à certains égards, cela devrait être
légalisé parce que c'est juste le  ss
profitable aux mauvaises personnes
ouais et il y a des choses plus importantes
à craindre
tu crois au bien je ne crois pas en
Dieu je crois qu'il y a quelque chose
là-bas en termes de
spiritualité commune je ne dis pas ouais que c'est Dieu en
soi  Merci